California is aiming to put a stop to
the often inhumane conditions of puppy
mills it's now the first state in the
nation to require pet stores to sell
rescue animals Artur Evans has the story
the Humane Society estimates more than
two million dogs sold in the u.s. each
year come from so-called puppy mills
like this one in Florida this unlicensed
breeding operation has overcrowded and
unsanitary conditions many dogs had no
access to clean drinking water and were
suffering from various medical
conditions the only way to shut this
cruel industry down is to take away the
demand animal advocate Judi Mancuso
helped pass the new California law which
requires pet stores to only sell dogs
cats and rabbits that are rescues in the
state of California we bring in over
800,000 dogs and cats into our shelters
and we kill over half why on earth are
we allowing this cruel industry to be
feeding our state with yet more animals
but the new law will still allow
Californians to buy animals directly
from reputable breeders Boris Jiang
sells pure brands along with rescues in
his Sante in a pet store if it was only
shelter dogs would you still be in
business no to sell the puppies that
allows us to do the adoptions the
reality is it takes the sale of a $1,500
dog to help fund the sale of a shelter
dog absolutely James says the new law
will likely force his business to close
but Andrew Kim who runs the pet store
chain healthy spot has a different
business approach the only animals here
are rescues we've saved over 500 dogs
and cats and hopefully we've built some
customers along the way as well Kim
believes it's not only the humane choice
but a savvy one where does the bulk of
your income come from if it doesn't come
from the animal sales
it's the supplies and services healthy
spot offers everything from treats and
toys to grooming services and his
business is growing Kim now owns 11
stores around the state when you
open your home in heart to loving animal
right like this dog here why wouldn't
you want to support the store where you
made that first connection how could you
resist faces like this right
the puppies hope you can't for CBS this
morning Saturday Carter Evans Los
Angeles
they are prettier I we adopted a rescue
and rooster is a blessing every day
no I encourage everyone to do it great
advice